as Britain's prime minister during a
pandemic Johnson was say several
advisers sometimes slow to make life or
death decisions you going to apologize
to the B families Mr Johnson but his
entry to the inquiry early Wednesday
morning was rapid I swear by almighty
God sworn in questioned then interrupted
right at the very start of his testimony
sit down pleas please stop victims
please sit down I'm sorry if you don't
sit down I'm going to asked the ushers
to get you to leave finally came the
former Leader's apology but I understand
the feelings of of these victims and
their families and I am deeply sorry for
the pain and the loss and the suffering
of those victims the anger inside and
outside the hearing beforehand was
evident indeed it was the overriding
emotion instead of solving a national
crisis his government presided over a
total disgusting orgy of narcissism he
did let the bodies pile up and the
elderly were treated as toxic waste as a
result over a quarter of a million
people died for Co from covid this busy
street in London has become something of
a shrine to the victims of Britain's
covid-19 pandemic tens of thousands of
dead but many families blame squarely on
Boris Johnson Louise Brown lost her
sister during the second wave of Co that
swept across Britain in late 2020
because I stuck to the rules I didn't
get to see
her um before she died and then I later
find out they were all partying
especially Forest johnon after he set
the rules saying you couldn't see anyone
and I'm just so angry about that this
campaign will continue to demand
accountability and answers with the
covid-19 inquiry designed eventually to
deliver both Villa Marx Al jazer
London
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from
alaz